[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
mieux lutter contre les incendies de
forêt
elle était 2022 plus de 62000 hectares
ont été incendiés près de 8 fois plus
que la moyenne des 15 dernières années
du fait du réchauffement climatique la
France est ainsi touchée par des feux
hors norme les sénateurs se sont saisis
du sujet d'abord en lançant une mission
d'information puis en déposant une
proposition de loi visant à renforcer la
prévention et la lutte contre
l'intensification et l'extension du
risque incendie lundi 19 juin 2023
député et sénateurs sont parvenus à un
compromis sur ce texte qui traduit les
trois principales orientations
préconisées par la mission sénatoriale
renforcer la prévention du risque de
feux de forêt et de végétation mieux
coordonner les politiques publiques et
faciliter le travail des équipes de
sécurité et d'intervention le texte de
compromis issus de la commission mixte
paritaire a ainsi conserver l'essentiel
des apports du Sénat sur des mesures
stratégiques et opérationnelles il
prévoit notamment la mise en place d'une
stratégie interministérielle et
territoriale de défense des forêts et
des surfaces nombreuses contre les
incendies et d'un cadre réglementaire
adaptable en continu en outre il
contient de nouveaux outils de
régulation entre la forêt et ses
interfaces et prévoit des incitations
financières à une meilleure prise en
compte du risque incendie par un
conditionnement de certains financements
et la mise en place de nouvelles aides
fiscales
les sénateurs regrettent néanmoins
l'exclusion des collectivités locales du
dispositif de réduction de cotisation
patronales accordées en contrepartie de
la mise à disposition d'employés
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
il déplore également que le crédit
d'impôt pour dépenses de travaux
réalisés en application des obligations
légales de débroussaillement aient été
retirés du texte de compromis
celui-ci sera examiné en séance publique
jeudi 29 juin
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]